ah e como seria se o shaolin fosse do
nordeste em ran
com 11 mil enfim desejo de menina
oi com você está beijo que ainda usa um
colar
que eu te dei mais será que você ainda
pensa em mim
metade
na esperança de encontrar você e do shin
pis assim eu e você pedir à frente então
me entenda deixar de narrar aí vêm aqui
[Música]
e aí galera chegou a hora de tudo bom
vocês já de início eu vou pedir aqui de
novo clique gostei no vídeo no vídeo
passado foi só esqueceu de pedir é só
uma esquete que gostei que gostei
aproveitar agora que do falei nada
interessam clique aí ficou então vamos
ouvir
e aí galera ronaldo bom que você olha só
que beleza hein mais uma vez estamos
aqui agora com este cabelo e essa
barriguinha com um pra você que quer
viver de internet quer ver no youtube
muitas pessoas já falei no vídeo
anterior que muita gente me pergunta
como fazer produto como é que papai
viver disso eu resolvi fazer isso e
fazer um curso online é um curso que
você vai se inscrever você vai receber
as aulas por semana eu mesmo da nossa
aula tenha de teatro também para quem
quer se soltar pequena de de como mexer
nas câmeras para quem quer aprender tem
tudo nesse curso mas já tem gente que se
sente inseguro fascinam isso mas se é
dom e sei que você tem é um negócio que
você não é gente aqui a gente aprende
com o tempo eu não achei meu primeiro
vídeo na internet que todo mundo fala se
este é o primeiro vídeo do isso não é o
vídeo que tem não é meu primeiro vídeo é
muito muito muito antigo mas eu achei
aqui eu vou assistir seu dia de quem tem
namorado vamos ver
oi mas que está tudo bem o dia dos
namorados na hora antiga namorada linda
muito linda não tenho namorada não tem
não tem a beleza não tem a feliz
aferição mas sim eu já saí mas não deu
certo e ativos muito muitos bichinhos
mago velho o meu deus saudade desse
metabolismo do óleo para mim nesse vídeo
tem vontade me dá um sanduíche na hora
da escolha 10 horas ela dormir na que eu
tava tudo que eu gostava e tinha outra
que a gente terminou porque a gente
gosta das mesmas coisas que a gente vai
fazer eu fiz a piada que nessa piada já
tive três namorados neste tipo de 15
anos
do céu 15 anos até 3 namorada eu estou
pensando que eu sou quem larissa manoela
gostava que controla
ela também gostava de filmes ela também
gostava de mulher e ela também foi boa
mas se não me engano essa piada nem fui
eu que inventei que ela existe e acho
que houve algum algum livro eu botei que
assim cara quando você está desesperado
para fazer um novo rei com médico pegas
cor dos outros acordos outro não é legal
fazer acordos ou às vezes a piada que é
parecida com a de alguém mas você mudou
tem alguma parada diferente o
diferencial da sua piada a isso é
interessante você descobre a desgraça da
tpm que acontece é que os homens pensam
tpm é um dia em que a mulher tá de mal o
dia que ela ama o mundo e odeia você
as meninas que estão ficando não tem tpm
é perceber não tem mas que ela esconde
ela embarca mulher é uma coisa muito
complexa que acabou né
o menino tem ppm mas que minha turma
ficando tem tpm ela esconde a guarda
mulher é o placar boa piada livro teve
já ai meu deus não sou e própria taag
adolescente você gosta vai afinar saca
só eu mas o vereador não é uma coisa
muito complexa é só tornou-se
adolescente você gostou da cidade
só que o sol que desgraça do morro bom
jesus no piauí em faca sol
saca só corri paulista onde carioca em
saca só assisti duas novelas sinhá sai
falando as coisas a casal belezas e
tinha um cara mais velho consegue o
dinheiro porque quando você está mais
velho e conseguem dinheiro lá no também
já está velha a ela que é um cara mais
novo como nunca
vocês são namorados
o minuto e 12 de vídeo acabou o meu deus
por isso que não ia pra frente o
bichinho vaca pra frente e se perguntou
o que quero da sé é porque nunca olhem
se é ruim é ruim inclui meu deus como é
eu fui aprendendo com esse tempo a
ciência pode ver aí que até os cortes in
do vírus são bonzinhos cortes em que
nesse tempo já estava ligado nas paradas
e como é que eu faço isso para fazer
sucesso no youtube
olhando eu vou dizer pra você que é que
não dá certo a fazer a primeira coisa
não dá certo clique batken o nome
chamativo demais e ovídio telefone ou de
um café ea minha avó
olha no que deu é a também meio a avó
com sangue e botou na na edição na cara
da pessoa e todo mundo é clicar que todo
mundo quer ver a desgraça o povo é que o
povo quer ver a desgraça eu vou entrar
quero ver saber só pagava depois eu
xingar o cara mas primeiro quer assistir
chega lá não tem que acontece ganha
acesso ao povo que outro não gera
segundo o coronel na festa o conteúdo
apelativo que é um conteúdo apelativa
agora foi o ano vai queimar as pernas no
óleo quente da cozinha em galera quantos
lic e se tiver tantos milagres que ele
vai beber o óleo quente pelo ouvido e
vomitar pelo olho e já viu isso alguém
chora óleo frito não gera porque abusa
você pode fazer algumas pessoas gostaram
mas outras pessoas não vão gostar pode
fazer sucesso pode dar certo ou tô
dizendo que não é pra fazer isso aqui é
um público muito específico para você
fazer eu mesmo tenho uma agonia eu tenho
a agonia de vídeo assim já eu juro por
deus que eu tenho algum dia a outra
coisa não dá certo a terceira quando dá
certo é spam que a espanha é você vai
toda hora comentou olha que saiu o meu
vídeo lá no ouvido o souto é que meu
vídeo ela mordeu o índice sou seu fã
você é o meu maior ídolo assistir meu
equipamento no meio mesmo quando o vídeo
do lucas engel luca já sou seu fã fez o
vídeo das homenagens assistir o vídeo
vai ajudar quem quer ser só seu filho
devido às homenagens em todo mundo vai
ver pode dar uma exibição maior vai dar
o que reter dislike porque é importante
para quem faz vídeo na internet não é
visualização não é um cara importante é
que as pessoas gostem de você que quando
a pessoa gosta de você ela fica com você
pra sempre entendeu já que a
visualização da pessoa que vai assistir
uma vez nunca mais vai voltar não
precisa o interessante é que as pessoas
gostem de você então essas três coisas
funcionam aqui bate o conteúdo relativo
spam não adianta sair todo lugar pode
ser uma pessoa volta e meia vai lá e
vejo a visualização a mais uma pessoa
que não volta mas nunca nesse canal eo
que é que dá certo que dá certo é fazer
um conteúdo tão bom que as pessoas
começaram a falar com os outros porque
viralizar não é adeus feita bombom foi
bem alta do youtube
ae generalizar quando a pessoa fala
bicho oito chaves pires é a virada só
pode vir desse cargo na massa e isso é
legal está o próximo vídeo a pessoa vai
querer ver pois eu tenho que gostar de
você como é que faz a pessoa gostar de
você tem duas coisas a identificação ea
mudança de estado emocional que a
identificação da pessoa
o vídeo faz um paralelo é assim mesmo eu
sou a assistir o vídeo cara falando hoje
a manter foi interessante porque às
vezes a gente viu de núcleo
a pessoa que está assistindo fã [ __ ]
tome field no culto da noite olha que
interessante isso a identificação que
vídeo eu te esqueço é sendai foi quase
60 milhões de visualizações de pessoas
que se identificaram e perguntar qual é
sendai foi o brasil é um país que só
metade da população tem acesso à
internet 3g
lá ninguém tempo todo lugar que você
chega e pergunta onde a cedae faz ideia
genial sucesso explosão viu se inscrito
isso a identificação ea mudança de
estado emocional é um vídeo que deixa o
foco o vídeo que deixa pouco estava
triste agora tá feliz ao ouvir o meu tem
mudança estar emocional mãe de rico e
pobre porque se lembra sua mãe foi quem
olha mamãe identifica lembra dela muda o
estado emocional quem quem não tem uma
mãe que perdeu lembra da mãe que tinha
quem tem a mãe que mora longe lembra a
mãe que está morando longe mostra pra
mãe assiste com a mãe da minha mãe
quando assiste se para porto velho a
loucura minha mãe quando assistimos de
rico e pobre criança de crescer de forma
mais choca minha mãe chora e lembra das
coisas
olha que loucura uma mãe e chora ao
mesmo tempo isso é a mudança de estado
emocional estudam aprendi em sete anos o
youtube foi 7 dino foi 7 semana não foi
o sétimo foi sete anos de outubro
debaixo de muito erro muita coisa ruim
que eu fiquei falando besteira piada
ruim corte ruim vídeo ruim mas eu
aprendi hoje a admiração carinho tem um
tratamento legal com meus fãs assim em
toda a rede social aqui no youtube mesmo
instagram cães quem segue nesta canção
que tem piada lá com esta grande
shopping center lapa tudo isso que eu
queria uma coisa pra que isso sempre
cresça mais e mais e aí tudo isso e eu
criei um curso vai sair a primeira turma
o discurso agora é um curso de como
fazer sucesso no youtube não quis que
existe não tem fórmula só que nesse caso
vou contar tudo que eu fiz meu canal
chegar a esse tamanho que é hoje um dos
maiores canais do mundo e disse você vai
aprender a desenvolver sua criatividade
e até mesmo que a travada carisma nem
para fazer um vídeo legal que a pessoa
que a ses goste de você
não só naquilo que você está falando de
você vós também para quem quer aprender
a fazer paródia quero fazer paródia
adoro fazer mas não sei cantar vai
aprender também improvisação edição
também quem não sabe a editar o vídeo
vai ter a equipe profissional
a audição pode falar como é dita ou
mexer nas suas redes sociais com a
parada bem legal ter o diferencial
processo criativo é para o meu lado
hoje a técnica de humor eu não sou
engraçado eu não tenho o dom pra isso
não existir lá eu vou te falar no curso
do tipo de vídeo no youtube atuação como
se relacionar com o público como ganhar
dinheiro com publicidade que pode fazer
esse curso cara de verdade assim eu
quero que faça esse curso é gente que
quer viver de internet que quer viver do
instagram do facebook youtube de
qualquer coisa de internet esse curso é
pra você você que não quer viver disso
não criança ae sei que eu sou fã do
índio que assistiu o curso não por favor
não gasta dinheiro com isso vai viver
sua vida vai brincar mas eu sou criança
e tem um canal no youtube meu sonho é
esse então fale com o seu pai eu quero
ninguém pedindo cartão de crédito e
pague
aí eu quero comprar e se não não pelo
amor não faça isso seu pai apoia que
você acha legal negócio de internet
ganhar dinheiro na internet peça seu pai
para fazer com você pra ele aprender e
ele já passou a se passar em massa que
eu tenho as crianças que parece a mão
então nem vou no meu show a e minha
filha youtuber olha e ela vem aparecendo
ae a criança pode falar hoje estou aqui
incluídos ou maior outubro
meu deus o dom da fala me de quando essa
criança tem a mãe faz em quatro meses
que meu deus senhor quer que essas
crianças estão virando o inverso de
larissa manoela está aparecendo então
não faça isso com seu filho por favor
deixe seu filho brincado não tenho nada
contra quem faz em vários canais aí você
deixar seu filho brincar se deixando o
seu filho à vontade ok também pode fazer
o curso vai também pode fazer o curso
não tem vaidade você pode fazer seu vlog
asunto bem estou aqui hoje para falar
sobre o novo remédio explorá-los vai
falar publicidade também pode ficar
tranquilo e legal do curso que tem coisa
que tem a era profissional para eles por
exemplo eu sei atuar mas aprende só
então muitas vezes não sei passar até
porque eu faço professor de atuação vai
pagar a ele explicar direito em favor da
edição eu sad tal aprender na marra mas
têm um cada edição para te ensinar já
rápido como fazer eu vou conversar tudo
isso tirar todas as dúvidas você do dia
5 agora dia 5 agora quinta feira às 8 da
noite 20 horas vai ter uma live que
nunca não pára nunca fui online só ser
muito massa quer todo mundo assistindo
tire todas as dúvidas vocês o curso é
online tinha saído de casa não você vê
daí vai ser de graça não poupa é [ __ ]
pessoal que é rainha devem ter que pagar
até pipoca também refrigerante para
assistir o curso se comem ea inscrição
porque vai ser quebras inscrição escutas
mas sim no dia 9 de outubro tá dia 9 de
outubro às 8 da noite abre a inscrição
se começar da gente demais eu eu paro a
inscrição podendo ficar gente de maio e
como sou 23 milhões de inscritos é uma
galera então se você quiser já ficar
atenta e para a conab a inscrição já se
inscrever logo no dia 9 às 20 horas abre
as inscrições está dia 5 à live aqui às
20 horas é todo mundo nunca fiz um live
por foi um negócio legal com as paródias
pra vocês também contar as piadas
eu quero que comece aqui embaixo coisas
sobre o youtube que você quer saber
sobre internet sobre fez qualquer você
quiser saber você quer viver de internet
que ganhar dinheiro na internet fomenta
aqui em baixo não se esquece de clicarem
gostei
aqui no youtube isso aqui é legal tá sic
gostei que no último dia 5 quando fosse
ela iniciasse notificado em questão está
ao vivo segundo quer perder lá que cê
quer perder 21 se inscreve no canal e
clique em gostei paquistão junto é mais